(lively banjo music)
- Automatically when I
think of American TV ads
I feel like I just
think of the Super Bowl.
- Weirdly sexist or be
it racist or homophobic.
- Let's watch some ads.
- [Voiceover] Black angus
beef and bacon it's so Tex.
- It's Texas versus Mexico.
- Totally, weirdly stereotypical cliche.
- There's a lot of flesh.
- I don't even know where to begin.
- I've got no idea what
this has to do with burgers.
- Are they playing on the border?
- I like those cowboys because
they were more interested--
- [Together] In the
burger than the hot women.
- And I can relate to that a lot.
- Yeah, same.
- And they just slapped
each other on the ah ah.
- I just want to go and join
my local feminist crew now.
- I've never seen a Hungry
Jack's ad like this.
- [Voiceover] And Cialis
for daily use helps you
be ready any time the moment is right.
- I used to work in a pharmacy,
I know exactly what this is.
Also, I can't get an erection,
- [Voiceover] Side effects
may include headache,
upset stomach, delayed
back ache or muscle ache.
To avoid long term injury
get medical help right away
for an erection lasting
more than four hours.
- That ad was like 90
percent all the health risks
that are associated with that med.
- You're gonna get hives,
rashes, swelling of the lips,
tongue or throat, you'll
bleed from your anus.
Oh, well, you know what--
- But you'll get an erection.
- Forever.
- [Voiceover] Ask your doctor
about Cialis for daily use
and a free 30 tablet trial.
- You can get free boner
pill trials in the U.S.
I think that's great.
- Get on it, Malcolm Turnbull.
- Not the boner.
♫ Your personal partner first in freedom ♫
- This is gonna be racist.
- Bail bonds, oh my god, oh my god.
- I mean, I've never even
heard of a bail bond.
It seems like a very strange concept.
- That's not how the law works.
- So it must be a pretty huge market
for there to be such a
need so that you can get
dropped home in a pink Hummer.
- I have no idea what that was for.
- I don't know what we just watched.
- Is this a legal, like, thing?
- Nail this little sucker.
C'mon, which one is he?
- I don't think I can do this.
- It's easy, just point to it.
- You thought you was gonna catch me?
Keep your mouth shut,
keep your mouth shut.
I'm gonna get outta here.
- This is like (bleep) up.
- Making light of domestic violence.
- A little racist, everyone
in this jail is either black--
- Or a goat.
- Who gave that the green tic
and I hope that they're fired.
- At Outback I start off with
a lot healthier appetizer.
- This is Jemaine Clement.
- Is that the guy from
Flight of the Conchords?
- It's the guy from
Flight of the Conchords.
And he's talking like he's Australian.
- He's from New Zealand.
He's not Australian.
- You know we are different.
Australians and Kiwis are very different.
- Can you imagine what it would be like
if like, Australia did an ad
and it was all about Americans,
but instead of casting Americans,
we just cast Canadians?
- Yeah.
- Hi, I am Bob, I am running.
Running for Iowa's open seat in the U.S.--
- He wants to be a politician.
- Oh, the dog was nodding.
- If you were the sexual
preditor and sociopath
who murdered my sister Lynette,
when you come to my front
door to do harm to my girls,
I'm gonna use my Glock.
To blow your balls off.
- Oh.
- That's not real.
- That just can't be real.
That's like what you see on South Park.
- Barely heard any Australian politicians
pledge to blow someone's balls off.
- Only good thing about
this ad is the dog.
That's a cute dog.
- Confirmed a lot of what
I thought about America
which is there's a lot of
messed up stuff going on.
- I feel like I need a stiff
drink after all of these ads.
- I would absolutely
want all of these ads--
- 100 percent--
- In Australia.
- Yep.
- I wouldn't even watch TV I would just--
- Just watch ads.
- Watch ads.
- Of course these ads don't represent
the entire American population,
but from what I've seen
it seems like politicians love
guns, every man in America
has an erectile disfunction
and everyone needs
legal representation for
breaking some kind of law.
- American ads might be crazy as (bleep),
but they're fun and I'm
pretty sure I love it.
(lively banjo music)